[Musique]
j'ai envie de lancer un défi à crécy
lui six mois je sais il ya des soirs
comme ça où tout s'écroule tout début
d'année
pourquoi tu parles de tes papiers tout
le monde j'ai pas les moyens qu'on est
petit toit cap haïtien dit je vous
invite bien depuis la voiture en plus il
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup et il a fait un énorme
cadeau à fatou et ça alors la prospère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
boîte à vois pas du tout facile réponse
jeudi deux jours après une soirée
rentrée des classes je peux vous dire
qu'il y avait beaucoup de stylos et
alors là conclut que la trousse
pour la garde de la double
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quatre à six d'entre elles
ouais des machines écrivez ce que vous
trouvez vous
[Musique]